if you're looking to accessorize your
car you should visit Findlay Toyota who
are the sponsors of this next segment
earlier I dropped in for a visit
[Music]
the Toyota 4Runner one of the top
selling mid-size SUVs the Toyota Tacoma
the number one selling small size pickup
truck for the past 17 years both are fun
to buy that's only half the fun the
other half is coming down to Findlay
Toyota and accessorizing them to fix
your lifestyle hey what's up John what's
up Jesse how you doing buddy good to see
you too beautiful 2022 Tacoma you do
them to work on it what do you got going
on today yeah so today uh these are the
factors that are currently on the
vehicle we're going to install some icon
17-inch rims needle Grappler Tires give
it a more beefier look you're giving the
beefier tire in this truck and this is
the stock Factory truck this is already
a nice big wheel right here yeah
absolutely yeah you get bigger tires uh
beefier tires it gives you better
off-road capabilities and that's what
this custom is trying to do he's gonna
lift it up a little bit too as well
absolutely underneath here so in the
back here we got a one inch lift in the
back this is the space right here that's
going to lift it up and we also install
the shock to accommodate for that travel
um in the back so you guys do it all
here
all kinds of accessories anything that
you need absolutely how big of a lift so
this guy is going about it and that's
the lift right there that's it right
there right there you guys go uh we can
go as far as about three inches
depending on what year we have all kinds
of Toyota recommended uh lifts we also
have aftermarket ones as well perfect
what's going on up front oh yeah up
front
so this is a whole TRD package that
we're installing on it uh this right
here is the strut and the spring that's
going in it it's gonna lift up the front
about by about two inches so the front's
going up two inches you got the back up
an inch and a half why are you doing
that so no less than the factory from
the back it's a little bit higher in the
front so this is actually going to
complicate it make it easier this is
this is off-road this is Beefy this is
ready to attack the the terrain you have
anything that comes to speed oh
absolutely we got some stuff around here
I can tell you all right let's do it man
so everybody's service bays are a tiger
so we have about 80 service days on the
inside we also have the loops in there
on the side wow that is
right here we got 36 Chevy that we're
working on doing a bunch of stuff to us
so here at Philly Toyota we pretty much
do everything all right JC So today
we're installing a supercharger on this
foreign give it a lot more power this
thing is going to make it go much faster
this is the supercharger right here are
there any other parts that go into the
supercharger yeah so right now at this
point we have it about halfway installed
on the vehicle so the superchargers in
over here we have the coolant system
components and electrical components
that we still need to install on the
vehicle so like I said about halfway
through at this point I do love the fact
that someone wants to make their 4Runner
go faster oh absolutely you know a
little bit little faster out there on
the 215. now you got a lot of parts
going into it as well but how is it with
the parts you guys get there pretty
quickly or is there a part shortage
there's parts stores on certain things
but we're really good about getting the
parts most of the parts we can get
within a couple days so we got lip on
trucks we've got superchargers on
forerunners and you guys hear everything
from that to oil changes as well oil
change as well maintaining repairing
other accessories as well whether it be
running boards bed covers whatever you
need you cover it all absolutely I think
we need to wrap up you and I will spend
some more time on this old Chevy back
here and if you guys need anything you
got to come down to Jeff Finley Toyota
you guys really do Do It All We Do It
All
thanks to Findlay Toyota for sponsoring
this segment call
702-566-2596 or visit findlaytoyota.com
for more information and we'll be right
back